un trou béant comme une plaie ouverte
après les bombardements russes
espagnols c'est incompréhensible
il n'y a pas de bases militaires ici
juste des civils c'est un village
désormais il ne reste plus rien de ce
village à une soixantaine de kilomètres
de kiev même l'école n'a pas été épargné
à 50 km de là comme de nombreuses
localités en banlieue de kiev
la ville d'hier pin est convoité par les
russes pour encercler la capitale face à
la menace d'une nouvelle offensive
les volontaires ukrainien évacuent les
habitants malgré les réticences de
certains
personnes les attendent nulle part alors
ils veulent rester là dans leurs
quartiers dans leur maison
mais nous essayons de leur dire de
partir et de fuir
dans le sud du pays marioupol continue
de souffrir assiégée depuis douze jours
par les forces russes le chef de la
diplomatie ukrainienne chiffre à près de
1600 le nombre de civils tués dans ce
port stratégique et ceux qui survivent
manque de tout l'aide est en route à
travers un couloir humanitaire mais les
bombardements constants rendent
l'opération difficile
malgré le danger des civils manifeste
amélie topol une autre ville du sud de
l'ukraine pourtant occupé par la russie
les habitants dénoncent le kidnapping de
leur mère vendredi par un commando rue
ce samedi le président ukrainien
volodimir zelensky a dressé le premier
bilan humain depuis le début de la
guerre environ 1300 de ses soldats
auraient été tués